this past weekend alright let's let's
crack open a can of this you know but
magic
[Music]
you got it
may your you felt that uh-huh man I felt
like a beautiful just like a big black
girl just jumped on my back and just
douve just down my throat into my soul
there at the end on that last on that
hit or riff let's catch another kitchen
another kitchen of a sniff of of this
[Music]
thing was tight that note was tight man
like they trying to put that note in you
but that note was you could I mean that
thing you got to really do some work to
get that thing out into the world the
tightness of that note happy thursday
guys happy thursday afternoon or
thursday morning actually it's gonna be
Thursday morning and I am here in in
America I'm coming to you live from Los
Angeles California it's Thursday January
18 in the year 2018 that's what I need
sometimes just that just let them stop
the merry-go-round stop the mist there
never remember there used to be so much
more peace in our everyday lives and
some people might not remember that if
you were if you're you know what I'm a
Jin myself here but whatever dude you
know I'm saying I'll date your
grandmother's frickin friend you know
and if you're a if you are if there used
to be so much peace ever you had so much
peace you did we're not as many electron
but I'm talking about when I was a child
and you would get home and there wasn't
as many of the electronics buzzing and
there weren't as many you know everybody
wasn't recording everything and put and
there just wasn't there was more peace
man I have a tough time these days
getting peace that's what I'm really
that's what I find I wouldn't do it I
would suck
you know I'll suck a nap but I you know
I suck a comfortable nap but uh or I'll
suck a quiet afternoon out of somebody's
debt you feel me I will suck somebody's
yeah for you know a couple hours of
peace and quiet that's what it's going
to come to that's what it's going to
come to you're gonna be walking you know
through the Tenderloin district or one
of these you know seedy areas in a
certain city and somebody's gonna be
like hey hey come here man you know how
about you uh you know how about you let
me suck your dick for a little peace and
quiet that's gonna be the drug because
it used to be so much more peaceful and
I think if you're you know I'm 37 I'm
gonna adult male and if you are probably
if you're 20 if you're 20 and this gonna
sound common um I just sound probably an
old guy that's what I sound like
though the old guys honest things used
to be so quiet but it used to be so much
more relaxing I mean I picked up a book
yesterday you have you tried to open a
book and look you're like what the [ __ ]
this is the worst video ever every time
I look at a book I'm like ah it is hard
it's just and it's just my ability to be
patient with with this with my ability
to be patient has just as is is
decimated it's decimated I have a tough
time I have a tough time but ya picked
up a book yesterday like an old
paperback wasn't even shiny or fancy
this like today this is pretty sad and I
like to read I like to absorb and Here I
am thinking that so I just wonder what
is this what is it what is the few what
does it look like here in the next ten
years you know when it when you king it
when there's you know when it has to be
video or your brain it's like it's too
slow cuz I also notice things that are
too slow for me now like if I call
someone's phone number and it doesn't
just go it doesn't go straight to
voicemail but it has that thing where
it's like to leave a voice message press
one to return to have the rich color
returners something-or-other press - so
help - if there's if it's not just you
know hey it's John you meter a cell
phone call me back if it's not that I
get pissed because I just didn't I'm
impatient I don't want to deal with that
extra seven seconds of [ __ ] that I
already have heard a million times and
then I don't even want to leave the
message then I don't even want to
[ __ ] talk to John anymore cuz I don't
like the [ __ ] that he's put in
between us I don't like you know
suddenly I'm angry at John because he
doesn't like he doesn't have the
machinery or the software that I vibe
with the most and I just get and it's me
yeah I know it's me you know I could go
live in the woods or live in a tent or
take more hikes or do other things that
would you know get me out of that realm
you know and take those you know and get
those you know those um what are those
things that stick to a boat scallops and
get those scallops off my body you know
cuz I'll let those scallops start to
build up by not being out in nature by
not swimming you know by not stepping in
a puddle or [ __ ] you know getting a
couple pats of mud and putting them on
your neck or putting them on your back
and just being a part of nature and
slowing it down you know I remember the
first time I went I didn't really go
camping I got locked out of the house
and you know me and my brother slept
under the eave
the house you know by the porch and dude
there was so much [ __ ] down under
there and you know we ended up actually
finding a plumbing problem that mom that
we had my mother didn't know we had it
and it you know almost really broke us
as a family financially once we found
that but you know but it was interesting
just being outside for a little while I
remember as a kid and slowing it down
you know I even just remember that just
I do remember a couple of moments how
quiet it was you know it was all so
quiet I found whenever I was when I was
young it was quiet you know I talked
about this on last week's episode that
it was quiet when my family would get
together when the power went out and
that was one of the but that was one one
time in my home that there was a lot of
peace in the air when the power went out
when I was a child because you know cuz
you got together your [ __ ] you got to
get where are you suddenly you needed
each other you had a cup there was a
commonality you know cuz my family
didn't have a strong fan there was no
familial bond there was none of that
[ __ ] you know it was just felt like a
just like a rescue center and we used to
fight and we used to fight at the table
and the best thing you could do during
dinner at my house was if you could make
fun of somebody hard enough till they
cried and they had a mouthful of food
and if you've never seen somebody cry
with a mouthful of food I mean it is
it's messed up yes I agree secondarily
to it being messed up it is hilarious
because they can't swallow because their
mouth they can't swallow because they're
crying and they can't cry that good
because their mouth is full of food and
so the I mean it was and that was like
that was winning at my house that's when
you got somebody when you had them
crying with that mouth you had them you
know jawed up on a [ __ ] couple grams
of salus berry steak and they was jaw it
up on that and running some you know
half a mouth still a full up of hot
bruh and then you hit him with a couple
of jabs and they started crying you hit
him in the feelings because in my
household that was the only way that we
showed attention to each other it was
the only time we even spoke to each
other I felt like when we were kids and
it's unfortunate I'm not saying that
that's a good way to grow up it wasn't
fun but it was you know it was real
and then the time when we enjoyed each
other's company when we're at peace when
we found some solace when we found some
you know I remember if the power would
go out I'd be you know doing whatever I
was doing I was living in my own world
doing what I wanted to do for me but
then the power went out and I was I was
scared you know I don't want to be alone
I needed more than just myself then so
we go and mom had two candles in there
and so we go in there and we need that's
when you know there was a necessity
there it created that created necessity
you know and I think it created with
that darkness even though you know we're
in our home I think even as a mother I
think there's just something innate you
know something that goes back to what's
important about motherhood and that it
you know it grips you in the neck and
you say when the power goes out where
are my children you know where are you
know these extensions of my body where's
the rest of me you know I'm assuming
that's probably what a mother feels
sometimes and so my mother you know we
would we find our mom and our mom wanted
to find us and then we would all be
together and those candles would be
letting you couldn't go outside of the
glow of those candles because it was you
know it would you don't know what was
out there and you wanted to keep tabs on
each other and your body your nerves
were alert so like you know if you were
tucked you know not touch and not being
you know you know sensual are being wild
but if you were just touching or
tickling each other as children you were
feeling it was so heightened and your
nerve your your ears my nerves would go
to my ears and I would have to I could
hear I mean I could hear I felt like I
could hear
the whole world because I would I would
just be so so I needed to I needed to
hear if anything was coming and not
spray and out I'm talking an animal or a
Farah you know uh Voldemort or a falcon
or a bad Falcon there's something
dangerous was coming in and needed to be
able to hear and suddenly my ear my ears
just developed these long capable arms
that reached out into the distance and
[ __ ] brought in every sound that was
around and I just and I loved that time
I loved it because our family was
together at those moments and we needed
each other and we wanted to be together
and we wanted each other to all be safe
and and there was and it was peaceful
and it was so quiet and that's the
quietest I remember it being was when
the power went out now fast forward to
now the power doesn't even go out as
much as it used to because now we have
generators and backup generators and we
got you know you know big Larry or
whatever who works down at the power
plant who's supposed to make sure he
presses this button if the rains come
you know or whatever we have all these
backups in order and it's just kind of I
don't know you you know you just
I missed that piece because for somebody
like me who it's hard to find it's hard
for me to find peace anyway to not have
it be as readily available as it was due
to you know technology and due to our
attention span I mean another thing is
just my attention span come on a span I
would barely call it that I noticed from
reading I'll read one paragraph by the
second paragraph my mind goes off to
something else you know what did that
girl say or you know man I haven't seen
her in a long time or start thinking
about sex I will think directly about
some dang be whole you know some
troubled behold that I've seen on the
internet or some set of tits that I've
seen on the Internet
you know immediately I'm reading a
[ __ ] chapter of Mark Twain dude and
then it's just like next thing you know
in my mind I picture Mark Twain
you know [ __ ] by a fence or something
the next thing you know my brain is gone
and I have to recalibrate boom let me
get back into this story and it's just
my attention span it's all everything's
it's just a different time it's a
different it's a different time but I
like this instrumental that came in here
this was Josh Porter and he sent this in
and it was called Luchadors Longfellow
that is what the song has called him up
lets you catch one more little hit of
that right here here we go give them
heavy tones right there boy sound like
somebody's trying to put the moves on a
[ __ ] ice cube right they're trying
like somebody's trying to just tickle
the nipples of an ice cube so cold and
so hot
at the same time happy Thursday to you
guys I want to tell you guys to man I'm
gonna tell you about them right now and
that's great block pizza and they got
them beautiful they got the they got all
kinda Frenchie they got these beautiful
pizza pies over there the Frenchie the
farmers delight the onion the cue the
caps got that Portobello oyster that's
shitake mushroom with the parmesan
fontina they got all that a great block
pizza and their link is on the YouTube
and they're over there in 1811 Pico
Boulevard on the way to the beach in Los
Angeles if you're headed to the beach
stop a gray block and thank you guys for
being with us I want to thank everybody
that's subscribed on YouTube you were up
to 21 thousand subscribers and man I
cannot even tell you how well if to be
honest to fill a couple of things I feel
some pressure you know and I know that
that's just me I just you know I want
you know I just want to continue to show
up and you know and help do some things
and make this thing bigger and broader
has some neat ideas that we're gonna try
and do some fundraising as a group that
I'm gonna be contributing to and do some
cool stuff you know a lot of big ideas
and a lot of those are starting to be
able to execute them and so but I'm
grateful to you guys because this is
kind of crazy like you know I started
doing this podcast and I didn't know I
knew I was going to talk about a stolen
even know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about you know and I have this horrible
shirt on if you can see on the YouTube
Wow
this shirt is really questionable and
and it looks some I mean it looks like
just like a damn it looks like a ding
semen cloud just busted right up over my
house and I you know got bashed out to
be honest with you and that I know is
gonna be a grody thing for some people
to think about it I'm sorry and I won't
say something like that again but but
here's the thing no by being a listener
by being a supporter and there's been I
can't tell you how many nice emails that
I've got
you know people just saying thanks thank
you and here's the thing by people
listening and being a part of this like
I hate to say this it might sound a
little bit you know greedy or
egotistical but it makes it make it made
me come back to do it you know like if
it wasn't for you guys listen and I
might have just you know might not have
gotten out of some of the ruts that I
was in because I needed this thing you
know I needed to come here and have some
people to talk to and to think about
stuff with and uh and so I'll just man I
really you know I'm very grateful I'm
very grateful there's been a lot of fun
we're gonna do a lot of neat things as a
group we're gonna do a lot of things
they're gonna lift people's hearts and
lift people's spirits we're gonna start
doing some things for some single
mothers out there we're gonna do some
cool stuff this year and I just want to
thank you want to thank everybody on
patreon that's been supportive and
everybody that's been listening and
subscribing and uh yeah it's just cool
you know all my life I just you know I
think I want you know I want to do
something good and helpful and I feel
like you know st. dang sorry dude I'm
getting a little caught up but I feel
like you know this this podcast is maybe
a way that I can you know help do that
sometimes so I'm not saying that I do
that I'm not saying that I think I help
I'm not saying any of that I just feel
like there's moments that we have on
here or that I'll read something that
somebody sent or a comment or something
that makes me it makes me it makes me
not think about myself for a little bit
and for me that's a blessing because I
think I grew up just thinking about
myself a lot because I had to to take
care of myself and now I don't have to
but I still have to shed some of those
old ways you know and I still have to
get my you know I don't think I'm
egomaniacal but I do think sometimes I'm
self-centered but now man I'm just
trying to get these reins off my off my
shoulders and get that drip drip out
into the world we're gonna do some cool
stuff and I appreciate you guys as uh
you guys support what else man
the Saints game we're gonna talk about a
couple things the Saints game you know a
lot of you guys were on here with me
last on Monday's episode when the Saints
game hit and I fell apart you know my
brother called and he called because we
usually talk after the game and I guess
I hadn't reached out to him and he
called and checked in we talked about it
on air and then lost man and they lost
and it was I mean the next day I
literally felt like I felt like they won
but they didn't advance if that makes
any sense
and I just felt bad for some of those
young guys and I felt like this there's
a last play and it's I think it'll
always be one of the one of the stranger
plays in NFL football where mr. Williams
he's going for the tackle and mr. digs
he plays on the Minnesota Vikings he has
the ball and mr. Williams tries to hit
that man and he misses him completely
but but he shouldn't have and for me I
think this is why it happened it I think
it happened because they called two
really bad penalties on mr. Williams
early in the game and mr. Williams this
is his first year in the NFL and this is
his biggest game of his career if you
look back there couldn't have been a
bigger game for this you know for this
gentleman and him I mean I think he's an
african-american gentleman he might be a
full black I don't know mix guy I'm not
sure but um but he plays defensive back
and I believe he's number 43
and he's had a great year I almost want
to say he I don't know if he went to the
Pro Bowl but he's had a great year and I
think that they make those bad calls in
the NFL early because they don't let
these guys play football anymore
and then by the end of the game he was
he was nervous you have these guys
nervous to play football and that's
weird because it's football and I just
think sometimes it's like these guys
know they're playing football yes we
want to make the game safer for them but
we don't want to make them so nervous to
make a play that they're
aren't anymore great plays made you know
I mean it cuz the way it should have
broke down was that he should have made
that tackle and that game should have
ended but he's afraid to touch the guy
now because he's already had to not good
pass interference calls made against him
so you got a scared rookie out there you
know just because of the way the play
calling he's worked his whole career to
get up to this point and now just
because of the way that the penalties
are being called he's nervous I just
only it creates the best product now I
think they should make the helmets had a
rubber make the field out of something a
little more cavalier you know maybe
denim something where these men aren't
you know they don't say kill each other
they can still hit each other because a
lot of these men are dogs a lot of these
men are Rottweiler B Sean you know
jacked up Russell terrier aficionado
[ __ ] pit bulls and they want to
attack so then you have them all you get
this awkward stuff going on there I feel
like most of the there's a lot more
anger going on at the end of the play
when they're yelling at each other then
there is on the field D then there is
during the actual plays these days but
yet maybe the NFL's more popular than
ever
I don't know I don't know what that I
don't know what the numbers are but for
me at halftime of that game I felt like
I was watching a really advanced flag
football and maybe that's just what the
world is becoming maybe we're becoming
flag football I mean it's hard to be a
man it's hard to be a man but I'll say
this as well that the one the thing that
consoled me and made me feel better than
I was talking about this on Facebook
live last night was that watching the
videos of the of the Minnesota Vikings
fans watching the videos of them feel
joy and feel you know feel excitement
and just just the joy just them just
elated just them to know that a miracle
can happen in a second that something
could change and that made me feel
picked up you know because it took me
out of me thinking about oh my team lost
and still my team had still lost but now
another team had won another group of
people had were feeling something good
so it made thus the the illness that I
was afflicted by the downs and I'm not
talking down syndrome I'm talking about
feeling down downs in the dumps down in
the dumps it even it lifted that a
little bit because if you added those
two sums up and invited in my to mmm you
know it sets me a little closer to the
middle then it does if I'm just down and
you divide that by two so that's what
did it for me but man what a season by
the Saints you know I'm still I think
Sean Payton got the luckiest draft ever
I think they've had the weird thing cos
he goes gotten out of control I don't
think he's been the same coach since
they won the previous Super Bowl when he
got divorced to me in this all
speculation you know this is all just me
being a fan I mean I love the Saints but
to me I feel like players respond
differently over the years to a married
man a man who's out there and his toe in
the line he's staying in and going to
work again and and leading by example
and and then he you know he was you know
he's hobnobbing with these ladies and
he's in a club and he's you know doing
the dougie and all this [ __ ] over the
years and I think that that changed some
of the vibe over there but it was tough
to see I wanted to see Drew Brees versus
Tom Brady and the Super Bowl I will
actually be in Jacksonville this weekend
poppin off down there in Jacksonville
and if you ever want to find a dead body
I you go to Jacksonville because it
seems like the kind of area where people
are straight up agencies you know what
I'm saying hiding carcasses and that's a
fact jack you know I used to drive on
the interstate when I was young I used
to peek out the window and look for
bodies in the distance and a lot of you
guys know I found two fingers in the
woods when I was young and
I'm over to the police and the man put
him in a ziplock bag and threw him in
the trunk of his car and took off
so I haven't found a whole body but I'll
be damned if I haven't found about at
least probably maybe 1% of a body all
right let's get into a little bit more
stuff that's going on here
it's hard to be a man these days it's
hard and I think the the toughness for
me I mean especially in Los Angeles
you can't good luck meeting a woman the
best you can hope for these days in Los
Angeles is you go out to the club don't
you know you don't get in a lawsuit
that's the big thing you know like it
should open up a club where it's called
NDA non-disclosure agreement everybody
signs on before they go in just to know
that you know if you wink at a woman
she's not gonna say you tried to you
took a swing at her with your eyelashes
because it's getting wild
I won't even masturbate locally I refuse
to masturbate locally I'll Drive out to
Riverside or I'll drive out there near
Commerce Casino then you know spray out
round around back there around that area
Ennis you know not at a park in a you
know in a safer area but I'm not jerking
locally you're crazy
you are crazy
I'm afraid even I'm thinking about
getting a bunch of uh garlic and hanging
it up because I'm afraid that some woman
out there is gonna buy a Ouija board and
accused me of trying to you know diddle
up in her seances owns so it's tough
it's tough I mean I think there's
probably a lot of men out there who are
you know getting involved in
homosexuality because they don't even do
it it's tired of it they're like look
dude let's go back to your place you
know let's both be [ __ ] just blindfold
each other and just act like you know
pretend you know maybe play sounds of
women in the background or something I
don't know
but it's tough and he had the big case
with Aziz Ansari we talked about it the
other day a little bit and I get nervous
to talk about some of this stuff and I
know I shouldn't but I'll say this I
mean I could see when I read this story
I could see this being Aziz type
behavior to me I mean you know Aziz when
the only comedians I've ever met where
when I shook his hand he didn't look at
me you know he just is like he seemed to
me like he has this vibe about him that
he's better than other people
which is fine maybe he is in some realms
but you know I haven't really uh you
know the only other community that
didn't look at me when he shook my hand
with Chappelle and that's fine I mean
Chappelle is you know he's really good
at what he mean he's he's a legend you
know his new special man I haven't seen
the second hour but that first hour it
might it might have saved comedy by him
talking about things that just to make
words okay to say but yeah you had this
instance it was a crazy instance and
then years later you know the girl
brings it up and it's it's tough you
know it's and I think some women are
probably confused about the me to do I
say something was it really something
you know if a woman's only had one one
sexual experience and it was
uncomfortable but over the say what'd
she say she had five more over the next
two years or she's going to have five
more and then she'll realize that it
wasn't uncomfortable that it was just
her scope of of knowing what was what
you know it getting involved with
someone was like sexually was limited
but she makes that claim now you know
and put someone's name out there because
that's the thing it's just so damaging
and maybe or maybe it was a bad instance
that a girl had you know but it's just I
think it's
I don't know how you get this right
because also there's there's some things
out there you know because you don't
want it seemed like it was handled when
I read back on this Aziz Ansari
situation it seems like it was handled
between the two of them she text in him
the next day and let him know that she
felt like she was not appreciated she
felt like he didn't take pride he didn't
recognize proper signs and I wouldn't be
surprised it sounds like he didn't but
it also sounds like there were other
signs where if you're a man that's in
the heat of that beat that you are not
going to be probably as keen to notice
them you know I mean when a man gets
overcome with such sensuality you know
it's almost like somebody takes out a
[ __ ] little mallet and starts just
beating a mallet at the base of their
spine and then that rattle goes up their
back and that's a sex rattle and they
start wanting to do sex and experience
sex and titties and everything or even
if it's it's just it overcomes it's a
limbic thing that arousal you I mean you
look and look in the jungle when a lion
see a girl lion in the distance or a
cheetah you know or a Lynx that's
wearing some tight you know they have
some tight fur on her legs he perks up
and at that point when he's perked up
there's it's tough to notice things it's
tough probably to notice smaller signs
because the foot the biological foot of
the universe that tells you that pushes
you towards procreation and doing skied
out of your body
it is already being accelerated so it's
it's like you know it's tough to how do
we manage that when it is beyond when it
when it is beyond it's not our
sometimes now at the point if you know
like of course I'm not saying if you
some girl if a girl or a guy if you're
doing male on male sex if a man is being
you know saying he don't want it he
doesn't want it he's not interested no
then you need to know that [ __ ] and we
all and part of us I mean a lot of this
comes back to people taking
responsibility for themselves no means
no that's easy that's why it is no they
gave an opposite to no and it's yes
that's the things but ladies also you
know to be so empowered and so in
control of yourself but then to show up
and it sounded from this Ozzy's story to
stay in an environment where it wasn't
the most suited for comfort I don't know
you know it just creates there's a lot
of gray area in all this is what I'm
saying and I feel like a lot of this and
a lot of this I've always said goes back
to what's going on in these classrooms
when people are children and when
children are children those same people
that's what I'm talking about because
the [ __ ] were teaching each other that's
the [ __ ] we're teaching our kids I don't
give a [ __ ] about most of it you know I
don't these days I don't care if my kid
can you know do times tables past 9:00
I do care if my kid knows how to share
his feelings with someone else and now
I'm not saying to share what he thinks
because everybody's doing that [ __ ] you
know everybody's woke and all this
[ __ ] and a lot of that is [ __ ]
to me you want to get really woke try
and understand what somebody else is
going through I'm just so
like a [ __ ] hash a hashtag does
nothing it does nothing you know there
might be some awareness but what it
really does for you know if you want to
help something go help it
donate you know I'm just so it's like I
don't know I don't know what [ __ ] I'm
talking about dude but it's hard it's
tough out there for men and it's and I
can't believe that these aren't the
things that we're starting to teach each
other and teach children and an
education system
half the people ain't even [ __ ]
paying attention at school anyway so
let's let's get in and let's get that
Gugu let's get into people's juju you
know crack opening a sternum get them a
orders thumping because when a man gets
out there he needs to know how to be a
man and you know with women there's so
much empowerment so much after-the-fact
empowerment let's get the empowerment
early let's get the empowerment let's
get to me too in second grade and start
teaching kids what it's like and what
kind of the vibe is like in certain
instances you know we're so Kay you know
we have such a weird thing about sex
here in America we have such a weird
thing about sex and maybe I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about and you
know what that's highly highly plausible
uh we have some calls that came in
though man I'm gonna I'm gonna go
through a couple of those a little bit
right now some neat thoughts and thank
you for hitting the hotline and that
number is nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three here we go
hey do this is Kevin from mycelia
California just listening to the podcast
I got the part where you said you paused
it before the Saints lost
I'm Saints fan too man so sad we'll get
him again next year
take it easy and you know what I can't
even remember if I already played that
call or not so but yeah will we get them
next year it's all there is to say
because only one team wins it you know
only one team wins it and there's still
some good teams in
to some great fan bases you know
Philadelphia great fan base Minnesota
great fan base you know they're gonna be
out there they're getting it's gonna
create some good new rivalries that's
exciting
Jacksonville's in there dude Jack
anything is good for Jacksonville and
I'll be there this weekend actually at
the comedy club so just want to let you
guys know that that I'll be in
Jacksonville at the comedy club this
weekend I will also be I'll be coming up
in Tacoma in March you can go look at
that it's on the calendar now and the
April dates will be on the calendar this
week a lot of dates are popping up on
there okay here we go with another call
that came in this was our Bri let's
check it
Hey oh this is Aubrey from Pittsburgh
we've had some fun little Instagram
exchanges sometimes
oh yeah I'll be out there with them yet
just walking dogs and this is a good
line and this isn't my line a friend of
mine told me this one time if you see a
lady walking a dog and the dog is a male
dog then you say to the lady you say hey
that's a pretty girl you got there and
she says um it's a male and you say oh I
was talking to the dog and then that
lets her know that you trying to you
trying to catch that little dirt you
trying to catch her a little dirty
frisbee in your mouth you know what I'm
saying her what the [ __ ] layman
talking about or let's go here we go
welcome the old puppies I listen to
today's podcast a little bit surprised
at the exchange with you and Zoe you
know and she's talking about Zoe Monroe
and Zoe Monroe even though she's named
after obviously a Civil War general who
also probably stole the name from a
Native American mu NRO
but Zoe Monroe is a but actress she does
you know all types of but activities and
you know tit circus and all of that sex
artists pornography and that she called
in a last week's episode um we're
talking about the darker art
all the time and how much you kind of
are sort of against masturbation with
the porn and everything and then to have
that I mean kind of weird okay so you're
saying it's kind of weird that uh we had
her on and then also but I'm but those
are things I'm against I agree and we
needed that we needed it we needed we
needed to talk to a pornographer to know
it's okay to to pleasure oneself to dead
artists and I've still come to
conclusion I don't think it's cool I
don't think it's cool
and I've also thought that we might get
a seance Iran here someone who does say
on sirs and get in touch with the poor
with one of the deceased porn artists
and see if we can ask them personally
and get their word so if you guys think
that's a cool idea or it's a weird idea
whatever put it in a YouTube into the
comments down there and we'll see kind
of what the vibe is on that not to
continue to discuss porn but to can but
you know it's it's tough and I've landed
on the fact that I don't think it's okay
to jerk off to the deceased and I don't
think that's crazy if you're driving
down the road and you're jerking off
okay you know this is just a hypothesis
you're driving down the road and you are
just touching your little [ __ ] long
green bean you know and that could be
your wiener or could be some lady's got
that freaking you know they got that uh
that tender lima down there you know but
you're touching that green bean and you
see a dead body and it's sexy it's
wearing a bathing suit
you're gonna jerk off know so that's
really where you know some of my
thoughts come from but I see what you're
saying we have around the we talked to
her and you know it's like well if we're
against the dark arts and we're trying
to stay out of our crotch and stay out
of you know vibe and then new there are
dirty pleasures then why are we
discussing things with her well we
needed her as a reference and
secondarily you know like I mean I I
would not want my sister doing
pornography you know it would make me
feel a certain way
[Music]
say and also wanted to have Zoey just
you know I guess I just I just wanted to
you know also hear her and not just
happy to talk about sex and just be
thinking about you know a little bit
more of a human take on what's going on
sexually you know when she said some
things that were interesting to me is
that that what she thinks her job is is
selling fantasies and I've never had it
put to me like that before
but that's a lot of witted that's it's
so it made it suddenly so obvious to me
because I would see things in
pornography and then hope to catch them
out here in the real life but most of
that's fantasy most that's not realistic
you know nobody's no chick is bringing
by you know a pizza and what's the [ __ ]
and not even have to get paid for the
pizza that's you know most of it most
chicks aren't hitchhiking and gonna [ __ ]
you and your car after they get in you
know it is fantasy and I didn't I never
even realized that to me I was just so
intent when I would cut it on the see in
the bodies and seeing the me you know
the um the angles and the and the just
just crotches just attacking each other
you know just like a damn you know just
like the Battle of you know Bolger and I
was so used to seeing that that I wasn't
focused on what else was going horner I
couldn't see what else was going on
so was interesting to hear her take on
it but that's why I needed we need to
have a reference and and so we asked her
because she still you know even though
it is tempting to have her around I
didn't go jerk off you know a text
wither and said thank you and that was
it you know but I'm sure there's a lot
of dudes out there who listen to the
podcast who checked in and next thing
you know you know they're out there
firing you know that body sauce out at a
whole new internet you know staring at
that dirty balloon not and getting a
peep at that thing
at that dark wink and it's out there
and maybe I shouldn't have it I
appreciate you bringing that up our
brain maybe I shouldn't maybe I
should've thought more about that but I
wanted to try and my you know in
hindsight I was seeing like maybe this
just kind of humanizes what's going on
here a little bit more okay I want to
discuss a little bit about zipper cruder
say you need somebody to do a job okay
say somebody hires you to juggle
you can't juggle right but the circus is
tomorrow so what are you gonna do you're
gonna look for a juggler well now with
zip recruiter you can post your job to
over 100 of the web's leading job boards
with just one click it's no more you
know
printing off you know juggler needed
juggler needed and posting those around
you know and having to cover up missing
dog posters just because you need that
you know that Handy ball handler for
tomorrow no not anymore
zip recruiter actively looks for the
most qualified candidate and invites
them to apply and that can be anybody
from a juggler to a CEO whatever your
business needs whatever your business
needs zip recruiter can help no wonder
80% of employers who post on zip
recruiter dot-com get a quality
candidate through the site in just one
day and you can find out right now wise
up recruiters been used by businesses of
all sizes and industries for free just
go to zip recruiter dot-com slash tpw
that's right go to zip recruiter com /tp
W and try it out for free it's the
smartest way to hire get that jugular
yep that's zip recruiter comm slash tpw
again that zip recruiter calm slash T P
W there's a speculation out there that
Donald Trump president Donald Trump paid
off a hooker that he allegedly slept
with at some point in his life I don't
know if the news stories are true or if
they're false but here's what I'm gonna
understand sometimes about the news who
[ __ ] doesn't think that this occur
like sometimes the news keeps saying
[ __ ] to me that I'm like no [ __ ] you
think I think he only only had sex with
one prostitute in his life
no he's Donald [ __ ] Trump he's just
like all these other I mean he's just
like [ __ ] I know dudes you have $30
and they've had sex with a hooker I bet
if you looked it up these days
I bet probably I bet 30% of men in
America has had sex with prostitutes
now that doesn't I'm not justifying what
happened but certainly if I see Donald
Trump yeah whoo that's a thing it's like
people think that this is news it's not
news to who like who does it who with a
real mind in their head looks at Donald
Trump thinks like ah he's never had a
prostitute or he's never paid a woman
for a crazy party like I just don't
understand sometimes you know but I do
notice that I look on you know if you
look on news sites every politician is
now being called a piece of [ __ ] doesn't
matter it doesn't matter what party
doesn't matter what affiliation all of
them because what I start to notice is
that Hollywood Hollywood is more
powerful these days than politics
Hollywood is our is our political it's
our politics you know the presidents are
these people that that are running these
huge businesses you know those are fit
those figureheads are obviously have
been made by the media to seem more
important or better or wiser and that's
where we are now and you can start to
see how because the media like these
news sites that's that's Hollywood like
what's happening is the news what's
happening is reality but the way that
it's presented to us by the media and
the
Media itself is that's Hollywood that's
a media so I and I'm not like becoming
some conspiracy theorist I'm not a dude
I just I want to check myself before I
let something wreck me and I just start
to notice I just started to notice it's
like me and every every story is about
Hippolytus out and I've always never
I've never thought politicians were the
cats me Alec who believes that anymore
you know I don't know if you can find a
hero because all these heroes that are
always you know sold to us they're not
real they all fail because we're not we
are mortal we can't be we can try to be
heroes but I don't know if we can you
know I don't know if we can be to a
level that triumphs this the
the the the value that is out there to
pull heroes down because there's value
in building them up and there's value in
building them down and breaking them
down I mean in all these you know all
these clean oh the meeting that all
these websites and the clicks that's all
it's a formula now build them up find
something that breaks them down then we
got to come back it's like you know it's
just a there's a lot out there that's
just it's formulaic now but I start to
see that you know the news just beats
have every politician now everyone and I
think it's because that Hollywood that's
up that's the politics these days they
have more power they have more power
than these over all they're the ones
running this show because they are
controlling the cameras and I'm not
saying that that's a bad thing I'm not
saying there's bad stuff out there that
everything's bad but I'm just saying to
me you have to have some awareness about
that and and I'm happy to be wrong on
that to dude I could be a [ __ ] weirdo
I really easily could alright cool I
want to get into a couple of calls that
came and we had a mother that called
last week and she's raising a son she's
having her second child and and she had
wanted advice on what what what's a say
to her son or how to behave to her son
and make him be a better man but right
before we get to that we had this call
that came in here we go hey you know I
was diving into the dog and we've all
been there brother and you're not a bad
guy for doing that
I mean hell I practically served him up
to you at last episode by introducing
you to you know to a new receptacle for
Dark Arts and it's tough out there for
all men right now
I won't even jerk off on land usually I
go out to appear a jerk-off I off appear
you know at least that way maybe I catch
international water laws or something
you know but who knows there's a you
know there's there's a lady 700 miles
with strong binoculars and next thing
you know I'm in court you know for
pleasure of myself out into the ocean
but anyway onward Christmastime while
all your exes come back into town or you
come back into town start hitting each
other up got a question about when does
that stop because I'm young 21 when does
that go away that your ex's stop trying
to link up every single holiday
21-minute but you got a nice skin on you
and I'm not saying that trying to be
wild with him but I'm saying that just
to you know because at my age you you
you like them to see in my skin it's a
it's on any anything it's on it's nice
you know you see some nice skin on a 21
year old boy like alder he gots nice
skin
you know and I'm recognizing where I
recognize it but um but hopefully your
question or your you think you're
talking about is people coming home from
the holidays and hooking up with their
exes or you know getting in touch and
booty call and look man ride that donkey
okay water that pony okay hey you know
feed hate of that aardvark you know H up
that Vaart because you want to keep this
animal alive because some of the best
times ever had was coming back from
college you know and being at home in
the summertime and catching you a little
bit of local trim you know maybe a girl
you knew and now she's graduating and
suddenly she got you know breasts and
she's 18 and you're 19 or 20 and next
thing you know y'all out there just you
know [ __ ] behind an optometry Center
somewhere off the interstate and you're
enjoying each other's company and man it
was fun and next thing you know she you
know if somebody's mom might get
divorced and you might be that you might
be that man she picks up at the workout
fitness center or she's buying a bag of
bread and next thing you know you
[ __ ] you need nim titties you know
and that kind of stuff can happen in it
and it's during that time in your life
when you can happen when it happens a
lot I noticed when you come back for the
summer because you know people's friends
or things have changed and they both
people are changing they're not sure
what's going on in the you know in the
dust is in the air and you got to get
out there and you know you got to ruffle
some dust and that's a good time to do
it that's what I found
so hopefully it doesn't in for you for a
while you know it throws something
that's a good time to throw some lines
out in the water because when people
haven't seen you know high school can
really it puts these it puts us in these
people put us in these boxes people put
us in these spaces we put each other in
these spaces we only see each other a
certain way and then after someone's
going away to college and have come back
and you start to see them a little
differently or they'll see you a little
differently and there's an opportunity
for some romance because you haven't
seen each other even been a part of each
other's losses you wonder what they have
and they wonder what you have even if
it's just a story or a moment or or an
experience there's something there's
there's natural planks there you know
where you can walk out in your plank and
show them a little bit of your wood and
they can walk out on your plank and you
know shum a little bit an air wood you
know and you can say oh look at this
this is what I have this is what I've
been doing look at in there like oh this
is there I've been doing and maybe you
just bridge up you know next thing you
know you're making love to some lady out
behind a damn [ __ ] Xerox copy Center
and you're like I don't have any
protection and she's like Oh doesn't
even matter you know I had a I had my
ovaries taken out you know I was in an
accident I had my ovaries taken out so
you know make it do what it do and that
happened to me one time back there
behind a I guess it was kind of like a
strip mall but also had some like a
little bit of a recycling center but uh
but that's a great question man and I
would say ride it as long as you can get
that get that summer hit get you know
because I'll tell you this sober sex is
for children when you [ __ ] when
you're older man it's all it's diluted
and there's you know you'll be [ __ ]
and you can't even get one of your socks
off and somebody's wearing a hat and
there's all kinds of you know somebody
they don't have cologne or somebody's
got a you know uh had a smoking issue
and have a trach pipe or hole and you
can hear - wind whistling and their
trach hole
but when you're young you can have this
and and so that's so then so you need
drugs and you need alcohol a little bit
of hit to get you through some of that
as an
old but as a kid man y'all fresh y'all
young y'all a rabbits dude you know you
could do backflips and everybody's me
you could you know you could [ __ ] do
whatever you want you can cultivate that
crop you know as a kid you can really
get out there and touch each other's ass
and people can feel it so I implore you
if you are young get out there and do
sex make it do what it do when you get
up here entities Middle Ages it's it's a
damn fiasco out here somebody got too
much cologne on her neck and next thing
you know you get it in your eye or
perfumes woman's cologne for woman so if
you young and sober you get out there
and do some sex man legal sex all right
let's take another couple of we had some
callers that hit up a hit us up and this
was in response to the young lady that
called in last week mother of two and
she called in and asked for suggestions
from some of our listeners as to what do
I what are some things I want to instill
in my son you know and I was grateful at
that moment because it made me think
about that and then my brother called in
and he and I were able to discuss it a
little bit just about you know something
some things we would have liked to have
had as children you know emotionally I
think is where some of this stuff landed
for us but here are some other calls
that came in and I want to get to some
of those here we go okay so yeah this is
Carl from Auburn California dirty Carl
you out there huh dirty Carl out there
homeward and I'm calling about the
question regarding what mothers can do
to kind of set an example not SMO
supportin that spans the evolution of
the family household through time is you
know the mother can set an example for
that child to show them what a real
woman is and how a real woman acts that
way when that young man grows to be an
adult and he goes and searches for his
woman he has a nice framework of what a
real woman's liked
and that's a great point Carl I
appreciate that that's hot Carl out of
there and hot Carl is a nickname for the
you know actually feces I think or used
to be anyway and I hope it's not anymore
Carl because I didn't and I'm sorry I
shouldn't even brought that up but it
used to be when I was younger and I
think that that's gone out of time so I
probably shouldn't have you know rebrov
I don't think about you that way yeah so
that's one thing you can you know so as
a mother too then so as a mother you can
show show by example you know be an
example for you know I think just having
that connection because then your child
at the very least is gonna want to have
a connection with a woman he seeks you
know it's I'm sure it's got to be scary
you know especially these days because I
think the parents should feel a
responsibility for the value of somebody
they put in the world because I have a
feeling that there's going to start to
be an evolution into like a merit based
living you know because one of the big
problems we have these days are people
that just don't have don't have a lot of
they don't want to be better they don't
want to be contributing members of
society for just whatever reasons and I
think that there's gonna hopefully be
some correction in that world will there
be some merit based society where who
you are as a person somehow becomes
quantifiable and that there's value
there I could easily see that I feel
like we're on the cusp of a huge
evolution I think emotionally and and
that's pretty exciting bro you know we
out in them [ __ ] emotional straights
thanks for that call Carl onward okay
let's listen to this call right here
here we go what's up Brandon from San
Diego boy that's down there in the dub B
boy that whales boo toll I'm calling
about the UH the mom who is concerned
about how to raise her son and this
relevant to me and I just wanted to put
this out there okay thanks for calling
more Mike you sent you know the mother I
think that's really important for them
to be there emotionally for their kids
supposed to their sons because sometimes
they don't get that from the father side
true especially if they don't have if
there's a father not in the household
and you know that's a lot of pressure on
the mother because she's playing two
roles now and if your mother doesn't
have schizophrenia or she's not you know
probably a transvestite or something
that can be probably even more tough I
mean I'm just saying I'm and I'm not
that's not a joke I'm saying that that
could be it's probably easier for some
of those people more the mother should
be empathetic and kind of and therefore
their son and emotional regards because
if they're not you know there's a time
when my mom was kind of disconnected
from that for me and I think later on in
life I kind of I seek that out you know
in girlfriend the relations and stuff
yep and I'm gonna stop you right there
and I appreciate your call Brandon but
I'm gonna say that too I mean I was in a
relationship when I was young and I
remember it was like I guess one of the
first time I was really in love you know
that young love is [ __ ] powerful do
when you're in love and you're young you
could start it you could start a truck
with your [ __ ] tongue I mean you
could power a damn building with you're
just just with a you know just with the
salt on your breath because you just so
does nothing I mean you are so hopped up
on hormones you know you could spit into
a cat's mouth and and knock it up and
and I remember yeah you know I had
issues from growing up with my mother
and then I met this I met a girl and we
fell in love and I'm when she broke up
with me I remembered you this is I mean
all my [ __ ] gets always freaking oddly
emo but I remember thinking that I'd
lost my mother you know and that's when
I realized yeah I have some I got some
stuff there you know I've got some
issues there where you know I mean I'm
looking for connections with women would
that are supposed to be fill when I was
younger and I think a lot of these
things go back to the fact that you know
um nobody's nobody's taking care of
children nobody's at home with them
there's not a family anymore we've you
know that's all it's and that's one of
the things that I don't like sometimes
or that one of the things that I
questioned about some goals of feminism
if it's just if it a lot of times it's
used
as a marketing tool just to get women
you know to sell them [ __ ] just like
everything else you know it's all like
yeah you get to buy this book but you
know next thing you know you have a
woman who wanted to have a family next
thing you know she's 42 years old she
has no kids she started a small business
somewhere off the interstate and she's
[ __ ] furious and miserable at her
life because she was led astray by uh
you know by some of the darker sides of
some of the feminist evolution and I'm
not saying that for everything but I'm
saying that that is a reality and that's
gonna be reality that for some and
that's gonna be reality that's gonna be
out there let's hear some more here we
go what's up - my name is Eric Cooper
thank you for calling for Virginia sir
honored I'm originally from Louisiana
oh you from that dirt huh from that boot
and we appreciate your service here
vocally onward I'm calling about the
girl with the question about her son
biggest and most important things that
you can instill at a child I think it
makes you better at so many things
you know you're a better lover for the
ladies you better fighter when you need
to be I just think it makes you a better
person overall you build character
whenever there's something made me
passionate when I was young man I'm
stumped I got nothing for that man but I
look I appreciate that thought passion
ladies put that passion in you boy and
nothing illegal you know I'm saying stay
out of that family sexual zone nothing
sensual with the family you know what
I'm saying I've always known that my
number one rule if you think it's incest
you'll remember this if you rearrange
the letters of sister it spells resist
and you could take that to the bank
here we go do vine man this is staffing
up in Lexington Kentucky for Stefan up
in Lexington Stefan let's go fellows
southern man calling in response to the
lady that wanted to know about how to
raise a young man into a real then I got
one comment and I think you'll
understand it being from the South okay
let's get to that - Stefan and thank you
for the call the best thing a mom could
do is love unconditionally but most of
or Tinley the person's number one
confidant in the world and a very good
friend the reason I say that is like
guarantee you meet a man who's close to
his mother and you meet a man who treats
women well hmm it's interesting you know
I think this is all new territory for me
and how you know seeing how people treat
noticing how people treat their mothers
and stuff I was so unaware of some of
the value of that connection I I didn't
really notice it going on around me but
that's interesting yeah I mean it there
was times I didn't treat my mother well
that's for sure
you know when I was probably embarrassed
of her for things of or ashamed or you
know and now I just wanted to be happy
you know it's crazy like now it's like I
almost have to let go of any issues that
were there between us whether she knew
about him or not and you know I think
the biggest issue I noticed growing in
my own life was that I just I wanted my
mother never seemed happy and I wanted
her to be happy
and I couldn't make her happy you know
she and I'd even notice it as a child I
just knew she wasn't happy and so I felt
like that was for some reason my fault
because a child everything in a child's
world everything revolves around them so
something's wrong they think that it's
their fault it doesn't matter what it is
you know they have to have it that way
to survive the world just revolves
around them you know a [ __ ] 4 you're
only thinking about his buddy you know
we're thinking about how his mom's day
went you know and you just you know I
remember as a child just I remember as
an adult now thinking back that all I
wanted was my mother to be happy and I
realize now that since I couldn't make
her happy when I was young it made me
feel like something was wrong with me
and I think that's a good point if you
can establish that confidence with your
kids and it might be tough probably I
bet that's tough ladies to you know be
able to break down those barriers and
talk about things direct with your child
you know with with a boy you know and I
wish you uh single mothers out there
well with that sort of journey because
that's got to be tough
because you know I bet with as a mother
you just wanted to be you know your
instinctual you wanted to be happy and
fed and home and safe and warm and then
it's hard probably to have the time and
the ability to go beyond that and
discuss and get into things where you
know that probably almost feel like
they're out of your role especially if
there's not another man to be around if
it's not a man to be around to do that
so I commend you moms out there doing
that all right guys I think that's
actually a pretty good place to pull up
the anchor right here I got to go to a
set tonight at the Comedy Store mr. Joe
Rogan will be up there and christina
pazsitzky and Bryan Callen and a couple
of other comedians I want to be able to
spend time with them you can check out
the dates on theof on calm slash tour
and and yeah I think it's just um you
know it's there's a lot of pressure on
men right now and then I bet that this
there's a lot of pressure on mothers to
make better men and then there's this
outside in you know and then there's
this this vibe out there that saying
women should even just be doing things
on their own that they don't even need
men and I don't know how those all fit
together well I don't know how you're
supposed to learn to treat a woman if
your mom isn't even at home or your
father isn't even at home you know we've
we've created a vibe where you know both
parents have to work or an environment
of society you know I don't know how you
know we expect people to know so much
when we keep distancing ourselves
connection wise you know whether it be
being on the phone or you know being a
wafer you know being on these iPads or
whatever and we're all I mean I can't
want to roll in these addictive meetings
for phone you know what happened to you
Larry you know it was that [ __ ]
update that Microsoft sealion are the
you know the Mac OSX sea lion up day
never been the same it's just like we
have it's just like we've created this
society where where we don't have a
family to help us be better or to help
us learn or to learn any of these skills
anymore how to treat each other you know
phentermine marriages are you know it's
all becoming extinct it's all like this
singular you you you do it you do it you
don't need someone else and then we
wonder why people are growing up and
don't know how to even be around other
people or don't know how to treat them
or why a guy you know treats a woman
like an animal or why a woman feels like
she got treated like an animal or why a
woman stays in an environment when a
guy's mistreating her you know or why a
woman feels afraid to talk about what
happened to her you know it's just I
just think we I don't know if what we
want innately and what we really want in
our hearts is what we are is the world
that we're creating or the world that
we're letting be created by people that
control it I don't know it's wild it's
wild dude it is wild but I appreciate
you guys being here with me and happy
Thursday to you guys and I want to thank
everyone we got to 21,000 subscribers on
YouTube if we get up to 30,000 men I'm
gonna do something special for you guys
I'll put out a comedy clip you haven't
seen or do something special so thank
you guys so much
hit the hotline if you have any
questions or thoughts or suggestions any
constructive criticisms as well for me
I'm always open to them you know that
number is nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three and if you have you
know and I'm not trying to be right than
anything we're talking about I'm just
trying to talk about it and I appreciate
so much the community that we're
creating here online and you guys be
good we go to yourselves you probably
deserve it you know that huh here we go
[Music]
that's Luchadors longfellow Josh maybe
if you have a lady over just put this on
just look at each other for a little
while see what the vibe is up at you I
bet you get a vibe you can trust if you
got something beautiful like this going
on in the background you know I get I
bet you'll get a classy vibe going over
something real I bet you'll make a
bridge you can trust y'all be good